war nur eins dieser straßenkinder jetzt
ist er ein geschäftsführer mit einem
globalen 450 millionen dollar
ich glaube nicht dass jay sie jemals
neun musiker war er dachte er ich werde
dass jaycee unternehmen aufbauen
niemand hätte gedacht dass er so weit
kommen würde das eher clubs und mode
linien besitzen würde und alles andere
was er tut er hat damit geprahlt über
die grenzen der musik hinaus zu gehen
und das ist ihm gelungen
jay ist nicht zum mainstream
übergegangen er nahm den ganzen
mainstream und kaufte ihnen eine
eintrittskarte in seine welt
er entkam den dunklen weg den so viele
andere genommen hatten es passiert die
ganze zeit in diesem wohnprojekt du hast
ein bestimmtes leben und es führt
nirgendwo hin dass führt entweder ins
gefängnis oder es hört zum tod seine
überlebensfähigkeit und seit darstellung
führten ihm auf die reise seines lebens
er ging von der straßenecke zum eckbüro
als chef das war bahnbrechend
jaycee ist ein brillianter text da ist
ein skrupelloser geschäftsmann und
jemand den jedes große unternehmen gerne
an der spitze haben würde
b sie hatte diese schrittweise aber sehr
tiefgreifende entwicklung vom stricher
zum chef und zu dieser phänomenalen
hiphop größen
anstatt nur irgendeiner zu sein hat er
sich zum ziel gesetzt der eine zu sein
und das ist einfach eine unglaubliche
leistung zu sagen ich bin nicht einer
sondern der eine
und das ist er der unbeholfene junge auf
dem klassen porträt shawn corey carter
der zum mega star jay z
sie wollte an unserem programm nicht
halten
shawn carter wurde am vierten dezember
69 in brooklyn new york geboren und war
das jüngste von vier kindern
er kam aus der hölle aus einem
kriegsgebiet das war dieser wohnkomplex
mercy project in den 80ern die tatsache
dass er das überlebt hat so glaubwürdig
im spiel zu bleiben sie ist einzigartig
rapper kollege und früherer mentor jesse
lebte im selben
wir haben mit viel gewalt zu tun gehabt
wissen sie viel mord drogenhandel drogen
das war ein glück für einige von uns da
raus zu kommen aber viele die wir
kannten haben es nie geschafft
seine musik handelte von seiner bewegten
vergangenheit aber er sprach selten
darüber sein offenes einstündiges
interview mit charlie rose im jahr 2007
war eine ausnahme die dinge die in
diesen vierteln an einem tag passiert
sind erleben andere in ihrem ganzen
leben nicht ich habe einen blick auf
dieses leben geworfen was mir hätte
passieren können wenn ich auf der straße
geblieben wäre
sie spielen russisches roulette mit
ihrem leben jeden tag 365 tage im jahr
irgendwann knackst du so ist das
es gab immer eine behörde kommt
irgendjemand untergeht
rosenblum laden jaycees lehrerin in der
sechsten klasse
diese kinder sind mit schusswunden ins
bett gegangen wenn sie in ein
klassenzimmer kamen lösten viele von
ihnen und ich ließ sie weil ich wusste
dass sie die halbe nacht wach waren
sie hat den jungen shawn corey carter
nie vergessen er war schüchtern und
extrem aufgeweckt er war
überdurchschnittlich gut im lesen er
hatte diese angeborene fähigkeit
später reckte er darüber gute noten zu
bekommen aber dass er tief in seinem
inneren dämonen hatte die aufgeweckt
worden er lächelte welten und ich weiß
nicht ob es traurigkeit war oder einfach
nur seine persönlichkeit aber er war
immer irgendwie gelassen und lächelte
nicht als sei sie elf jahre alt war
verließ sein vater die familie in seinem
song dezember fonds sein geburtsdatum
schreibt er er sei ein zerrissenes kind
ich glaube dass er jaycee irgendwie kalt
gemacht und isoliert sehr verletzt und
ich glaube das hat ihn zu dem
berechnenden geschäftsmann gemacht der
er heute ist unsentimental
seine texte spiegeln distanz wieder
sei sie sagt in seinen eigenen songs er
habe seinen bruder in die schulter
geschossen weil er ein schmuckstück
gestohlen hat
das geld war knapp seien
alleinerziehende berufstätige mutter und
es gab nur wenige jobs für einen
teenager
aber der drogenhandel brachte das
schnelle geld
dj lässt dass sie ein führender new york
es ging darum schnell große summen
bargeld zu haben und niemandem
rechenschaft ablegen zu müssen
im grunde ging es darum geld zu
verdienen so gut wir konnten und als er
jung war war das halt crack verkaufen
auf der straße
michael cooper journalist und
filmemacher
es ist eigentlich seltsam der crack
verkauf hat ihm beigebracht unternehmer
zu sein die bedürfnisse und wünsche der
leute zu verstehen und eine nische in
dieser firma welt zu finden
seine liebe zur welt der platten begann
zu hause
seine mutter hatte diese plattensammlung
die in der gegend legendär war und jeder
kam immer um musik zu hören
jersey ist ein genie er hat ein
enzyklopädisches wissen über alle
möglichen musikstile
es ist nicht nur hip hop marvin gaye
curtis mayfield barry james brown
natürlich aber auch rock'n roll die
stones
[Musik]
sie bekam keine musikalische ausbildung
hatte aber instinktiv das gefühl dass
rap sein weg aus diesem leben sein
könnte er schrieb texte auf servietten
auf papiertüten es strömte aus ihm
heraus
er hat gesagt dass er sieben oder acht
neue songs gleichzeitig im kopf
speichern kann das hat wirklich etwas
über die datenmenge aus der verarbeiten
kann
sie war er ein sehr schneller rapper
und aber seine rap songs hatten auch
melodien das war einzigartig zu der zeit
ich habe vom ersten tag an ihn geglaubt
er 15 wir räumten und wir fingen an zu
vibrieren
ich hörte dass er pures talent hat es
ist einfach talent in seiner reinsten
form
cheseaux war als erster rapper bei ihrem
records unter vertrag
1988 nahm er in london das album work to
the jazz auf er nahm den 18-jährigen
jaycee mit und stellte ihm diesen song
des albums hatte keinen erfolg und jay
sie kehrte nach hause zurück
ein kurzer ausflug in die
plattenindustrie bei einer enttäuschung
hatte ihm aber die augen für eine viel
größere wettbewerber er war fokussiert
genug um zu sagen weißt du was ich kann
das nicht ewig machen mit drogen tieren
denn das kann nur auf zwei arten enden
entweder du stürzt oder du gehst ins
gefängnis
ich hatte tolle leute um mich herum als
ich an dieser weggabelung stand soll ich
entertainer werden oder auf der straße
bleiben ich habe mich entschieden
entertainer zu werden und es hat
geklappt ich habe den richtigen weg
eingeschlagen und habe es nie bereut
er machte sich in einer anderen art von
straßenschlacht einen namen
es gab rap kämpfer auf der straße die
nahkämpfe a cappella einfach aufeinander
losgehen und so hat sich jay durch die
straßenschlachten einen namen gemacht
und alle dachten wer ist dieser typ und
da fing es eigentlich an
er trat jahrelang auf partys und in
clubs auf bekam aber keinen
plattenvertrag frustriert schlug er
einen anderen weg ein
ich war von anfang an gezwungen
führungskraft zu sein denn ich musste
versuchen einen vertrag zu bekommen
bekam aber kann ich ging zu jedem
einzelnen platten label und bekam keinen
deal also hieß es entweder aufgeben und
zurück auf die straße gehen oder mir
einen eigenen weg schaffen um gehört zu
werden
1994 lernte
der gerade erst im künstlermanagement
angefangen hatte
das war damals so ein junger unternehmer
der vor allem werbung für partys machte
aber eher manager auch einzelne
auftritte
wenn man das setzte große hoffnung auf
den 24-jährigen jaycee sie gründeten ihr
eigenes label roc a fella records mit
einer dritten partnerin corinne dix bank
sie druckten ihre eigenen cds machten
werbung packten aufkleber an club türen
sie fuhren durch die stadt und
verkauften die cds aus dem kofferraum
1995 wusste jeder in new york alles über
hiphop und wusste auch wer sie war
rockefeller hat es auf seine weise
gemacht sie finanzierten ihre videos
selbst auch viele ihrer touren weil sie
wussten die mehr geld sie ausgeben
würden sie auch für sich behalten
es waren ihre gewinne das war es was er
wollte sein geschäft das rockefeller wie
eine kapitalgesellschaft führen
rockefeller veröffentlichte jaycees
debütalbum reasonable doubt sie
verkauften den drei monaten über 500.000
cds
eine solide grundlage um weiter zu
wachsen
sie waren sehr gut in dem was sie taten
sie machten eine super promotion und die
musik von jaycee war so gut dass er das
wichtigste ist und dann ging es richtig
los und wurde zu dieser underground
sensation
in dem hitalbum reasonable doubt trat
auch ein klassenkamerad von jaycee auf
die beiden rapper aus brooklyn traten
oft zusammen auf bis zum 9 märz 97
in der nacht wurde notorious in los
angeles von einem unbekannten attentäter
erschossen
jaycee war erschüttert aber es war auch
der moment in dem er der prominenteste
rapper des landes wurde er war sehr
traurig weil er ihm sehr nahe gestanden
hat aber gleichzeitig wusste er dass es
eine erstklassige gelegenheit wahr diese
lücke zu füllen eine echte stimme von
der straße eine intelligente jaycees
wachsendes ansehen erregte die
aufmerksamkeit der musikindustrie größen
russell simmons und leo cohen und ihres
plattenlabels def jam
ich wollte rockefeller in der def jam
familie haben einfach weil ich diese
infrastruktur hatte
und ich brauchte wahnsinnig kreative
leute um diese infrastruktur zu nutzen
1997 kaufte def jam 50 von rockefeller
records für 15 millionen dollar
es war eine partnerschaft 50 50 es half
ihnen dabei das nächste level zu
erreichen und das gab ihnen eine
beteiligung
und genau darum geht es bei jesse und
beteiligung bei all seinen geschäften
bekommt er immer etwas an dem er
festhalten
will ich in holland
doch dann kam ein seltener fehltritt das
album in mailand ein
[Musik]
ich glaube das problem war in my life
war kein besonders gutes album jesse
klang plötzlich weiter um ein breiteres
publikum zu erreichen
des hardcore fans stellten seine
glaubwürdigkeit in frage
er sagte das album sei ihm entglitten er
brauchte eine wende und das schickte ihn
zurück in seine bewegte vergangenheit
hat noch gleich war ich meine das album
war sein thriller das war sein michael
jackson
das war sein erster crossover hätte und
das thema in den kontext des mars ii
projekts zu stellen ist ziemlich
brillant und es hat funktioniert das war
eine riesen erfolg
es schadet nicht dass er eine irrsinnige
arbeitsmoral hat er hat wirklich sehr
sehr hart daran gearbeitet dass zu
kreieren und zu promoten und es hat sich
gelohnt hat noch live brachte die sie
1999 einen grammy für das beste
rap-album jaycee der superstar war
wieder da
es braucht so viel um voran zu kommen um
von einem unbekannten zu einer
berühmtheit zu werden
und ich denke er war bereit die firma
war bereit und die fans waren bereit
die 50 vor city tour für hard knock life
brachte 18 millionen dollar ein aus
album weitere fünf millionen
ende 99 gründeten jaycee und seine
partner das mode label rocawear mit dem
sie in 18 monaten 80 millionen dollar
umsatz
er versuchte wie andere zu sein
pickens oder donald trump sozusagen am
ende ging es ihm darum irgendwo in den
hamptons ein haus zu haben und einen
maybach zu fahren was er tatsächlich
auch tat wissen sie was ich meine
was auch immer der erfolg ihm gebracht
haben mochte frieden war es nicht sein
temperament kam plötzlich und heftig
wieder an die oberfläche es war etwas
das nicht hätte passieren dürfen und er
würde die als erster sagen das ist ein
schwerer fehler war mit 29 war jaycee
ein hip hop superstar und chef seines
eigenen multi millionen dollar
unternehmens er hatte jahre damit
verbracht sein image zu pflegen
bis er am ersten dezember 99 dem
produzenten lens kit kat club in new
york mit einem messer
konnte lara gut und vertraute hat als er
von angeblichen raubkopien hörte rammte
er ihm eine 3 zoll klinge in den bauch
er hatte ihn gewarnt damit aufzuhören
und er tat es nicht dass alles in einem
raum voller zeugen er hatte alles zu
verlieren
sie wurde wegen körperverletzung zweiten
grades angeklagt er bekannte sich
schuldig und bekam drei jahre auf
bewährung
er hat fast alles durcheinander gebracht
aber er kam damit durch und sah aus als
wäre er der teflon rapper der teflon
rapper lernte dann seine diamanten diva
beyoncé knowles kennen
jahrelang vermieden sie erst über ihre
beziehung zu sprechen
es hat lange gedauert bis er diese
beziehung öffentlich bestätigt hat das
zeigt wie viel angst er da vorhatte zu
erkennen wie echt das war all dieses
teflon muss der entfernt und das
vertrauen wieder aufgebaut werden sie
ist die frau die in dieser hinsicht das
unmögliche geschafft
während sich sein privatleben beruhigte
nahm sein geschäftsleben fahrt auf mit
mehr hits und auszeichnungen
ende 2001 erzielte seine modelinie über
100 millionen dollar umsatz
ein jahr später machte jersey ein
schlagzeilenträchtiger geschäft mit
reebok
start von translation advertising
es gab noch nie eine nicht sportler der
einen so großen stil mit einer der drei
top marken abgeschlossen hatte nike
adidas reebok wir verkauften innerhalb
einer stunde 10.000 paar
und dann bauten wir 100 millionen dollar
franchise mit dem namen escada auf
alles was er berührte schien feuer zu
fangen
auf beyoncés solokarriere als er in ihre
erfolgs single crazy in love auftrag
[Musik]
als ihr album durchstartete schockierte
er seine fans und verkündete seinen
rückzug aus dem osten
weißt du ich bin zufrieden mit dem was
ich als solokünstler erreicht habe ich
frage mich was könnte ich noch erreichen
ich glaube er wollte einfach für eine
minute abstand nehmen er hatte das
gefühl alles getan zu haben was er tun
konnte
aber auf der anderen seite wollte er
vielleicht auch sehen wie die leute
darauf reagieren dass er in rente geht
der größte leben der rapper
sein abschiedskonzert fade to black im
november 2003 im madison square gardens
war sofort ausverkauft jetzt sollte das
büro seine neue bühne werden
in tucson vor 2004 kaufte def jam die
restlichen anteile an brocke verlag für
zehn millionen dollar
sie gaben bekannt dass jaycee präsident
und vorstand von säften werden würde mit
einem drei jahres vertrag im wert von
weiteren acht bis zehn millionen dollar
[Musik]
wenn man sich seine vergangenheit
ansieht gibt es viele leute die ihm als
mentoren zur seite gestanden haben er
lernt er alles was sie ihm zu bieten
hatten und dann als er alles gelernt
hatte und er es nicht mehr brauchte ging
er weiter
[Musik]
bis ende 2004 hatte rocawear 300
millionen dollar eingespielt
er kaufte damon dash und rocawear
closing für 30 millionen dollar und
verkaufte sie anderthalb jahre später
für 204 millionen an den mode riesen
iconix
der typ ist ein genie und jedes mal wenn
er einen deal macht ist er
wahrscheinlich der klügste typ imran
im hinterkopf denkt ja weißt du ich habe
geschäfte mit leuten gemacht die viel
furcht erregender sind als du er
beobachtet die leute was sie tragen was
sie tun wie sie zucken wie sich ihr
gesicht bewegt und dann wenn die zeit
reif ist kommt er mit seiner forderung
aber
er fand noch eine weitere rolle die des
philanthropen anstatt nur geld zu
verdienen begann er es zu verschenken
er gründete die shawn carter stipendien
stiftung für bedürftige studenten
2006 traf er sich mit kofi annan bei der
uno um auf eine umweltkrise aufmerksam
zu machen die globale wasserknappheit
alle 15 sekunden steht dein kind ich
freue mich sehr rauszugehen nicht nur
ein rockstar zu sein sondern auch zu
helfen es hat ihn zu einem globalen
botschafter gemacht seiner
persönlichkeit eine neue dimension
gegeben man kann ihn nicht mehr einfach
nur als rapper bezeichnen
als chef von def jam records baute
jaycee die karrieren von künstlern wie
rihanna & young jeezy aus und war aber
auch bereit für einen weiteren eigenen
head drei jahre nach seinem rückzug
veröffentlichte er kindern kam das album
verkaufte sich in der ersten woche über
680.000
2007 endete sein vertrag bei dem er nahm
die rechte an seinen aufnahmen mit eine
potenzielle
ehemaliger musikredakteur beim time
magazine und jetzt redakteur der
bloomberg
ich denke dass einzigartiger und jesse
als geschäftsmann ist dass er genau weiß
wo er sein will und nicht entgleist er
ist opportunistisch war aber von anfang
an auch sehr strategisch
er glaubt dass ein geschäft nicht
erfolgreich ist wenn die andere seite
nicht auch gewinnt er ist ein winner typ
vielleicht neigt er dazu selbst etwas
mehr zu gewinnen seine langfristige
strategie umfasste eine reihe lukrative
werbeverträge mit dem konzern giganten
budweiser heineken und co
er weiß sehr genau was er zu tun bereit
ist und was nicht er würde sein image
seinen namen und den guten willen nie
für geld für drehen oder opfern
jeder wollte mit ihm geschäfte machen
im april 2008 unterschrieb er beim
konzert giganten live nation einen
zehnjahresvertrag der touren
veröffentlichung und aufnahme gefasst
als die einnahmen der plattenindustrie
rückläufig waren kam live nation mit
einem sogenannten 360
was bedeutet dass sie ein stück von
allen bekommen was er tut für sie war
das brillant denn während der kuchen in
der musikindustrie immer kleiner wurde
bot dieses unternehmen einen viel
größeren kuchen und garantierte
einnahmen sie nahmen einen teil des
risikos und die belohnung über viel
größer in derselben woche besiegelte er
einen weiteren deal die presse stellte
fest dass er und beyoncé verheiratet
waren
wenn jaycee und beyoncé heiraten ist das
als würden bmw und mercedes zusammen
gehen das war die stärkste promi marke
der welt
und dann die neue new yorker national
hunder die sie natra von seinem thron
stieß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das album the blueprint schrieb
musikgeschichte es war das elfte nummer
eins eine mehr als elvis presley der
king wurde von einem hip hopper
[Musik]
dass jaycee elvis überholt hat ist
einfach bemerkenswert
es führt ihn wirklich aus dem reich des
hiphop und bringt ihn in die oberen
ränge oder den höchsten rang der
popkultur ist jetzt 40 jahre alt er
könnte mit 50 milliardär sein
sie wollte sich im geschäft profilieren
und er wollte dass das noch lange
nachwirkt sein ehrgeiz ist phänomenal
und hat eine wilde geschwindigkeit
er ist schnell er ist wütend er wollte
schon lange ein zeichen setzen das hat
diesen kerl am laufen gehalten
dass jemand der im grunde eine outlook
persönlichkeit war zum massen
unterhalter und geschäftsmann wurde ist
einfach eine enorme leistung